eskalierende gewalt in nahost bei
hunderten raketen und luftangriffen
sterben palästinenser und israelis tote
bei angriff auf schule ein 19 jähriger
erschießt im russischen kasan wahllos
kinder und jugendliche schummeln und
drängen immer mehr menschen in
deutschland wollen sich eine impfung
erschleichen
patientenschützer fordern strafen
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen bei
den heute -nachrichten am dienstag die
vom sport hat norbert lehmann für uns
ein stück von mir
lange war es eher still im
nahost-konflikt doch seit einigen tagen
kann davon nicht mehr die rede sein
seit gestern wurden hunderte raketen aus
dem gazastreifen gegen israel abgefeuert
zwei israel ihnen sterben dabei die
israelische armee reagiert ihrerseits
mit massiven luftangriffen auf das
abgeriegelte küstengebiet und hat nach
palästinensischen angaben 26 menschen
getötet darunter auch kinder
die kurzen distanzen machen die lage so
gefährlich jerusalem und der
gazastreifen liegen gerade einmal 70
kilometer auseinander
von dort abgefeuerte raketen schlagen am
häufigsten kurz hinter der grenze ein
zum beispiel in der stadt aschkelon über
die neuesten entwicklungen berichtet
michael b warum die raketen aus gaza
fliegen zum teil im sekundentakt und
nicht selten gebündelt auf ein ziel
längst nicht alle werden deshalb vom
abwehrsystem iron dome abgefangen
besonders hart wurde die kleine stadt
aschkelon im süden getroffen wenn die
sirenen heulen versuchen die menschen
schutz zu suchen doch viele wurden heute
überrascht zwei menschen starben
dutzende wurden verletzt
ich hörte die explosion am morgen ein
lautes buh ich konnte nicht glauben dass
unser haus getroffen war
gott sei dank ist den kindern nichts
passiert
mit weit stärkerer militärischer macht
schlägt die israelische luftwaffe zurück
sie zählt nach eigenen angaben auf
militärische ziele unter marktführer
doch unter den über 20 toten und
dutzenden verletzten sind auch viele
kinder
ich saß mit meinem kind zu hause
das fing an zu zittern und fiel aus
meinen händen alle meine fenster sind
zerborsten es gab keine vorwarnung
nichts
israels armeeführung sagt ihre
operationen dauerten mindestens einige
tage auch ein krieg am boden sei nicht
mehr ausgeschlossen
trotz des ungleichen kampfes lehnt die
hamas jede vermittlung ab
auch sie könnten noch militärisch
eskalieren drohen die islamisten
militärisch kann hamas nicht gewinnen
aber politisch gelingt es ihr durch den
konflikt vor allem junge palästinenser
weiter zu radikalisieren
denn denen hat auch israel keine
perspektive für friedliche veränderung
zu bieten
in lod kam es am abend zu gewaltsamen
protesten israelischer araber und auch
jerusalem bereitet sich auf eine weitere
nach der konfrontation vor
dort hat heute eine rechtsextremistische
siedler gruppe zu krawallen aufgerufen
ja michael beverungen tel aviv die
konfrontation wird immer bedrohlicher
jetzt gibt es eine neue drohung der
hamas michael ja es gibt diese neue
drohung sie ist gerade öffentlich
geworden und sie lautet wenn israel
nicht sofort seine angriffe auf gaza
einstellt dann wird die hamas auch mit
dem beschuss von tel aviv mit raketen
beschießen dass sie diese drohung
drohung wahr machen kann und wahr machen
will daran gibt es keinen zweifel nach
dem beschuss von jerusalem gestern
tel aviv und jerusalem liegen etwa von
der gleichen distanz etwa 70 kilometer
auseinander
und dass israel seinen beschuss des
gazastreifens einstellen wird das ist
ebenfalls unwahrscheinlich netanjahu der
premierminister hat gerade angekündigt
im gegenteil die gegenschläge noch zu
verstärken
sellerie wie so gut wie es geht seit
gestern vorbereitet die öffentlichen
bunker sind geöffnet aber die stadt muss
sich nun darauf einstellen dass es
tatsächlich auch hier
raketeneinschläge gibt danke für ihre
schilderung michael nach tel aviv nach
russland es war der erste schultag nach
den frühlingsferien in der großstadt
kasan und es wurde ein schrecklicher tag
ein 19 jähriger schoss in einer schule
um sich
es soll auch eine explosion gegeben
haben mindestens neun menschen wurden
getötet etwa 20 verletzt viele von ihnen
schwer
das motiv des täters ist unklar axel
sturm berichtet banges warten vor dem
krankenhaus in kasan angehörige hoffen
auf gute nachrichten noch immer schweben
menschen in lebensgefahr
meine schwester schrieb meiner mutter
jemand schießt hier ich habe angst ich
bin sofort zur schule gefahren
gegen 9 uhr 30 marschiert intersky wohl
in das schulgebäude an seiner schulter
baumelt ein repetiergewehr kurz danach
panik schüler springen aus den fenstern
im dritten stock der täter feuert auf
lehrkräfte und mitschüler
meine tochter ist da drin mindestens
neun menschen sterben mehr als ein
dutzend werden zum teil schwer verletzt
es ist schier unglaublich die
spezialkräfte können den mutmaßlichen
täter lebend festnehmen
sie fixieren ihn an händen und füßen in
sg 19 jahre alte management student
unauffällig bislang heißt es aber im
besitz eines telegramm kanals auf dem er
sich gott nennt und auf dem er am morgen
noch postet heute töte ich biomüll
sein motiv ist zur stunde noch unklar
klar aber ist in ganz russland besonders
aber in der stadt kasan trauert man an
diesem tag nach deutschland
die korona infektionen gehen zurück
immer mehr bundesländer lockern
in berlin könnten zu pfingsten freibäder
öffnen sowie gaststätten ihre terrassen
in schleswig-holstein dürfen gäste dann
sogar in den lokalen platz nehmen
voraussetzung ist dass die sieben tage
incidents für fünf werktage unter 100
bleibt das gibt das
infektionsschutzgesetz vor nur hessen
und bremen haben bislang noch keine
geschlossen antoine kurschilgen über ein
land der unterschiedlichen
geschwindigkeiten lebensfreude in bayern
hotels castro und handel dicht in hessen
deutschland beim thema corona ein
zweigeteiltes land die einen stehen noch
auf der bremse die anderen lockern und
öffnen ab donnerstag gilt ja dann die
neue einreise verordnung auf deutscher
ebene
wir waren jetzt bereichs ist es möglich
ab morgen den kleinen grenzverkehr
wieder zu lassen so dass die möglichkeit
besteht einkäufe besuche bei verwandten
und freunden zu machen dies alles
zugrunde gelegt haben dir jetzt vor
die erste stufe zu gehen das ist ab
morgen ab dem 12 das haben wir am
freitag auch schon angekündigt da ist
glaube ich die allerwichtigste nachricht
zu sagen dass der einzelhandel ohne test
und maximal mit einer person auf zehn
quadratmeter geöffnet ist in hessen will
die landesregierung morgen bekanntgeben
wie es weitergeht
noch ist von lockerungen nichts zu sehen
die hotels zu die gastro auch ich würde
mich auch über den frisch gezapftes bier
freuen und draußen gerne sitzen langsam
denke ich das könnte mal auch lockere
wellen man davon zu früh öffnen und
wieder rückläufige werden was die zahlen
angeht wer geimpft ist genießt in
deutschland seit sonntag wieder mehr
freiheiten das weckt auch neid und
missgunst und so versuchen einige sich
diese freiheiten zu erfüllen indem sie
lügen bei alter beruf oder
vorerkrankungen
wer erwischt wird fliegt ohne spritze
raus ansonsten hat das aber keine
konsequenzen
es kommt den einzelfällen immer wieder
zu diskussionen weil die menschen gerne
geimpft werden möchten was auch
grundsätzlich richtig aber wir sind
verpflichtet uns an die im priorisierung
zu halten wer mit seinen daten schummelt
wer sein beruf verschleiert sein alter
verschleiert er muss auch
strafrechtliche konsequenzen beim import
regeln erwarten
zurzeit ist es nicht mal eine
ordnungswidrigkeit das
gesundheitsministerium prüft seit
monaten ob das geändert werden muss
impfen ist ein weg aus der pandemie das
betonte heute auch der bundespräsident
beim besuch einer arztpraxis in berlin
schauen wir auf die aktuellen corona
zahlen für deutschland
das robert koch institut meldet 6125
neuinfektionen binnen 24 stunden das
sind 1409 weniger als am vergangenen
dienstag 283 menschen sind in verbindung
mit cupid 19 gestorben
die bundesweite sieben tage incidents
sinkt auf 115,4 von offenen läden oder
anderen erleichterungen noch weit
entfernt ist der erzgebirgskreis in
sachsen
die region an der grenze zu tschechien
hat derzeit eine inzidenz von fast 280
zählt damit bundesweit zu den hotspots
schon seit dem herbst sind die
infektionszahlen hoch und sie sinken nur
langsam thomas bärsch berichtet eine
pressekonferenz in der sorgenkind region
erzgebirge mit ihren hohen instanzen und
den niedrigen impfquoten doch nun
verstärkt sachsen hier die imf logistik
an allen fronten mehr impfstoff mehr
teams und das örtliche im zentrum bleibt
länger offen bis in die nacht die
nachfrage stimmt
ich habe nämlich in sehr sehr kurzer
zeit auch für diese mitternachts impfung
sind möchte fast meinen wirklich
ausgebuffte termine
warum sich das corona virus hier in den
sächsischen bergen so hartnäckig hält
bleibt für viele ein rätsel das auch
hausarzt andreas schuster nicht mit der
einen antwort lösen kann
eine rolle spiele womöglich der
familiäre zusammenhalt hier in der
region das problem sei dass viele nicht
glauben oder vermuten dass menschen
denen sie geboren sind
doch auch einstecken können das heißt
also was im bekannten- und familienkreis
doch die infektions stattfinden dazu
kommt dass corinna langsam an den nerven
zerrt 14 monate pandemie das sind doch
14 monate einschränkungen und regeln
wieder halten sich vielleicht eine ganze
reihe infektiologen zeigen für die
pandemie müdigkeit verständnis und
machen auch kommunikationsfehler dafür
verantwortlich wenn sie immer wieder
hören noch vier wochen lockdown noch
vier wochen beschränkung danach wird
alles besser und dann wird es nicht
besser und es wird noch mal verlängert
das ist eben das was die menschen mürbe
macht und das muss man akzeptieren und
verstehen es helfe hier nur weiter
überzeugungsarbeit und die im floristik
zu stärken wie ab sofort auch hier im
impfzentrum annaberg im erzgebirge in
den usa dürfen nun auch 12 bis 15
jährige mit dem impfstoff von beyond
eckpfeiler geimpft werden
bisher lag die grenze bei 16 jahren auch
in der eu hat der hersteller bei montech
die zulassung für kinder und jugendliche
ab zwölf jahren beantragt die
europäische arzneimittelbehörde ema will
in den nächsten wochen über die freigabe
entscheiden
pflegekräfte in deutschland haben bei
der bezahlung aufgeholt das zeigt ein
vergleich der vergangenen jahre
seit 2010 sind ihre bruttogehälter um
rund 35 prozent gestiegen etwa 14
prozent mehr als in vergleichbaren
berufen
das geht aus zahlen des statistischen
bundesamtes hervor
mit der so genannten queen's speech hat
die königin in großbritannien heute die
nächste parlamentsperiode eröffnen
das ist tradition pandemie bedingt in
sehr kleinem rahmen und in einer zeit in
der das vereinigte königreich ganz
besonders uneinig ist die folgen von
corona und briggs it und aktuell ganz
besonders in schottland ein immer
stärkeres streben nach unabhängigkeit
nach abspaltung von london
mehr von den herren die briten geben
bekanntlich viel auf ihre traditionen
doch auch hier musste heute der pandemie
tribut gezollt werden im auto und nicht
in einer kutsche fuhr die königin zu
ihrer 67 parlamentseröffnung vor einen
hut trug sie und keine krone und dem
sonst bei dieser gelegenheit berechnet
vollen oberhaus verloren sich nur wenige
lords und abgeordnete die queen verlas
was die regierung plant zuallererst ging
es selbstverständlich um corona die
priorität meiner regierung ist eine
nationale erholung von der pandemie die
das vereinigte königreich stärker
gesünder und wohlhabender werden lässt
als zuvor das erfolgreiche impfprogramm
in großbritannien hat sicherlich mit
dazu beigetragen dass premierminister
johnson und seine konservative partei
vergangene woche bei den regionalwahlen
in england die großen gewinner waren im
rest des königreichs aber rumort es in
schottland siegten die nach
unabhängigkeit strebenden nationalisten
klar wales wählte links und in
nordirland kam es zuletzt immer wieder
zu unruhen im zusammenhang mit der
umsetzung des brh exit vertrags was
bleibt ist das beschwören weiteren
zusammenhalt meine minister werden die
stärke und integrität der union fördern
dies war der erste offizielle auftritt
der queen seit dem tod ihres mannes
prinz philip ein wenig einsam macht ihr
da zumute gewesen sein angesichts der
schweren aufgabe ihr königreich
vereinigt zu halten nun nach china im
bevölkerungsreichsten land der welt
werden zu wenig babys geboren die
gesellschaft altert rapide
laut der jüngsten volkszählung ist die
einwohnerzahl in den letzten zehn jahren
nur um
5 prozent gestiegen auf jetzt rund 1,4
milliarden menschen
ein grund ist die ein-kind-politik die
rund 35 jahre die geburtenrate regelte
und vor fünf jahren abgeschafft wurde
der kindermangel könnte langfristig die
wirtschaft bremsen stefanie schöneborn
das ist eine klassische chinesische
familie schön schön ist neun jahre alt
und einzelkind seine eltern sind es auch
familie john ist das ergebnis der
chinesischen ein kind politik erst seit
2016 dürfen familien offiziell zwei
kinder haben
doch für die meisten ist das zu teuer
die erziehung eines kindes ist aufwendig
das kostet geld zeit und energie pro
semester zahlen wir neun bis 10.000 euro
für die extra kurse mein mann und ich
sind auch bei der einzelkinder wie
chinesen sind es so gewohnt das
stadtbild von peking ist tagsüber
geprägt von alten menschen und es werden
immer mehr
denn laut volkszählung leben knapp 1,41
milliarden menschen in china davon sei
jeder fünfte über 60 experten gehen aber
davon aus dass die offiziellen zahlen
nicht stimmen und chinas bevölkerung in
wahrheit schrumpft und noch älter ist
die schnelle überalterung der
bevölkerung hat zu einem rückgang der
wirtschaftsdynamik geführt die zahl der
erwerbstätigen sinkt bereits seit 2012
entgegen offizieller daten
dadurch ist das wirtschaftswachstum
niedriger so kann chinas
bruttoinlandsprodukt dass der usa
langfristig nicht einholen
die kommunistische regierung will wohl
in zukunft zusätzliche staatliche
unterstützung schaffen damit die
chinesen mehr lust auf kinder haben
engine wächst in einem land der
einzelkinder auf 35 jahre lang hat die
kommunistische partei die ein kind
politik befohlen jetzt bedroht die
demografische zeitbombe chinas traum des
großen wirtschaftlichen aufstiegs
und nun zur zweiten fußball bundesliga
und zum spannenden kampf um die
aufstiegsplätze arbeit ja und da hat
holstein kiel einen ganz wichtigen sieg
errungen
das nachholspiel gestern abend gegen
hannover 96 gewann die störche mit 1 0
und klettern in der tabelle auf den
zweiten und damit direkten
aufstiegsplatz
das kieler kollektiv um trainer ole
werner schnuppert schon bundesligaluft
nach 15 minuten landet der ball im tor
doch faire geste der koreaner lee
signalisiert sofort sein handspiel wie
die zeitlupe belegt kurz vor der pause
ist es reese der flanke und fin bartels
trifft zum 1 0
hannover im tiefschlaf völlig frei
spitzelt der routinier den ball vorbei
an torwart hansen hannover durch in der
zweiten hälfte biol schuss streift die
latte aber es bleibt beim 1 0 kurz vor
ende verletzt sich aslan am knie ein
wermutstropfen im aufstiegskampf der
kieler der schon am donnerstag mit dem
nachspielen regensburg weiterhin und der
hsv hat das erste spiel unter interims
trainer horst hrubesch mit 5 zu 2 gegen
nürnberg gewonnen und damit die mini
chance auf den aufstieg gewahrt
der erste fc köln wird ab nächster
saison von steffen baumgart trainiert
auch wenn die geißbock-elf absteigen
sollte der 49 jährige kommt vom
zweitligisten sc paderborn mit den
ostwestfalen gelang ihm als coach der
durchmarsch von der dritten liga bis ins
oberhaus des deutschen fußballs baumgart
erhält in köln einen zweijahresvertrag
zum giro d'italia heute die vierte
etappe des rad klassikers von piacenza
nass ist oder sieger der us-amerikaner
john dombrowski deutschlands bester
fahrer emanuel buchmann kam als 26
lange hält sich buchmann linksaußen mit
der flasche im mund in der gruppe der
klassementsfahrer aber an der letzten
steigung nach fast fünfstündiger
regenfahrt verliert der deutsche den
anschluss auf die topleute um den
früheren toursieger bernal vorn holt der
amerikaner john dombrowski als ausreißer
den etappensieg der zweite heute
alessandro de marchi aus italien
übernimmt die führung in der
gesamtwertung und emanuel buchmann vom
deutschen bohrer hansgrohe team verliert
34 sekunden auf seine härtesten
konkurrenten um den rundfahrtsieg das
was von sport ja danke norbert und wir
haben zum schluss in dieser sendung noch
große musik in der mailänder scala
nach sehr sehr langer corona pause
wieder ein konzert vor echtem publikum
500 glückliche konnten dabei sein
lange war es hier traurig still jetzt
wieder applaus für die künstlerinnen und
künstler sicher ein schönes gefühl
dieser applaus auch der mai bleibt
vorläufig ziemlich nass mit gewittern
und regen gleich mehr dazu beim wetter
von esther lee so viel von unserer seite
schön dass sie dabei waren das heute
journal mit claus kleber und drei
viertel 10 und uns gibt's morgen wieder
punkt 19 uhr ihnen einen guten abend
[Musik]
einen schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter mit pauken und
trompeten also mit kräftigen gewittern
wird die wärme im osten deutschlands
abgedrängt hauptsächlich schuld daran
ist dieses tief 4 und von westen her
setzt sich allmählich hoher luftdruck
zumindest vorübergehend mal durch so
wird es im westen deutschlands
auflockern ansonsten gibt es aber
kräftige gewitter im osten im süden
teils ergiebigen und anhaltenden regen
bei tiefsten temperaturen von 15 grad im
osten deutschlands 6 grad an den alpen
und in der eifel morgen dann kräftige
regen weiterhin im südosten deutschlands
bis zur elbe hoch und er ist ebenfalls
langanhaltend ganz im westen lockert es
bei hohem luftdruck auf und die sonne
zeigt sich mit höchsten temperaturen von
19 grad im osten und am rhein
11 grad an den alpen die kommenden tage
bringen uns weitere schauer am
donnerstag sogar noch einmal kräftigen
regen nach osten hin 11 bis 17 grad am
freitag gibt es 13 bis 18 grad dazu auch
gewitter samstag bis 20 grad und damit
ein schöner abend